In China, authorities in the central province of Hubei...
...say another 242 people have died from the coronavirus outbreak...
...that has killed more than 1,300 people since December.
In Belgium, NATO Security General Jens Stoltenberg held a press conference...
...after the NATO defense ministers meeting, condemning the attacks in Idlib, Syria,...
...and calling on the Taliban to stop the fighting in Afghanistan.
In Britain, former finance minister Sajid Javid...
...resigned a month before he was planned to deliver the government's annual budget.
Javid said that Prime Minister Boris Johnson wanted to reappoint him,...
...but he was unable to accept the new conditions and resigned.
Hundreds of women in Iraq marched in Baghdad calling on the United Nations...
...to support their protest against alleged corruption, discrimination, and gender-based segregation.
Finally from Hungary, an endangered baby pygmy hippopotamus at the Szeged Zoo...
...was presented to the public for the first time since its birth in January.
The hippopotamus will be with its mother until it turns one and a half years old.